[Music]
welcome back Heather again and hello for
me Evan I'm a technical curriculum
developer for Google cloud if you're a
data driven Enterprise you've likely
been met with an explosion of data
growth in recent years you need to find
the best way to store all those
terabytes and petabytes at scale so
welcome to episode 3 and here's we're
going to introduce you to Google Cloud
Storage it's a storage solution
specifically suited for your volumes of
both structured and unstructured data
data doesn't just mean rows and columns
of numbers anymore you may want to store
unstructured data like messages
documents multimedia files web pages and
so on whatever your storage requirements
are security availability and cost will
be your three key considerations cloud
storage aims to meet all these
requirements at its core Google Cloud
Storage is massively scalable storage
solution and it runs the exact same
back-end that powers Google's own
applications like storing Gmail's email
messages the billions of high-res google
photos and all the data that's
associated with searching and indexing
the internet so how do you know which
type of storage option for you to choose
from cloud storage offers four different
kinds of storage multi regional regional
near line and cold line you can check
them out in more detail here so let's
take a few examples say you wanted to
store disaster recovery backups the
rarely need say once a year then you
would consider a cold line storage
you'll get a lower cost per gigabyte
stored since you will be accessing your
data as frequently way on the other side
of the spectrum say you wanted to
support streaming data like videos games
or your applications here you want to
optimize for high global uptime so you
want to consider something like multi
regional or regional storage instead the
three key factors you want to keep in
mind when choosing a storage option is
availability or how frequently you need
to access the data minimum storage
duration so asking yourself are you
archiving monthly backups or storing
short-lived data and finally pay-per-use
pricing for storage and access whichever
option you choose they are all offer the
same throughput low latency high
durability and security
securing your data is always top of mind
all applications and data and Google
Cloud Storage benefit from the same
security model that Google itself uses
to keep its own customers safe when they
use Gmail search or other Google Apps
data encryption takes place on the
server side as soon as the data is
received before it's even written to a
disk and stored you can also provide
your own encryption keys for server side
encryption Google cloud platform and
Google's own infrastructure is certified
for a growing number of compliance
standards and controls it undergoes
several independent third-party security
audits you can refer to our first
episode for more information on the
management of access control using cloud
I am everything that you store in cloud
storage is contained inside of a bucket
buckets are these elastic containers
that hold your data and the metadata
that's associated with it and they help
you organize and control access to your
data the Google cloud platform console
UI can be used to perform simple storage
management tasks for cloud storage
including the creation and management of
buckets this and more advanced tasks can
be performed using the GS util
command-line tool and now for the fun
part
hands-on quick labs you can check out
the link to start the quick lab here in
this lab you will use a Google cloud
platform console you are too old to
create use and manage a storage bucket
so be using the console version in this
lab but you'll be able to do all these
operations using the command-line as
well if you wanted you can check out the
cloud storage QuickStart CLI to learn
more and keep in mind this lab will take
you about 30 minutes to complete ok so
here we are inside the quick lab the
first step that you're gonna be doing is
creating that storage bucket let's go
ahead and do that now now for step two
we're gonna upload some objects to it
follow along okay so step three we're
gonna make these objects publicly
accessible using the Google cloud
platform command line here we go well
that's a wrap we hope you enjoyed this
episode and would love to hear more
about how you use or would use Google
Cloud storage
don't forget to keep visiting our on-air
webinar series practicing inside of
those quick labs and taking a look at
our blogs all the links are found down
below
you can also learn more about google
cloud storage there are on-demand
courses on Coursera thanks for watching
and we'll see you soon check out last
week's episode where we take a look at
machine learning we'll discuss a used
piece from Google and run through a
section of our ml engine quick web